if there's anybody you can trust about
masculinity it's definitely me usually
around this time I would be dedicating a
video to the lgbtq+ representation but I
kind of want to take the AI that I use
on those topics and focus it on
something different I'd like to talk
about positive masculinity in film and
television now
you're probably more familiar with the
term toxic masculinity and this is
basically going to be about the opposite
of that before we get too far into it
though I feel like I should address
toxic masculinity at least briefly just
so that folks understand what it is I'm
contrasting against because this is
absolutely not
a there is no such thing as toxic
masculinity video so let's back up and
talk about what toxic masculinity is
actually hold that thought first let's
sidestep and establish what toxic
masculinity isn't it is not the idea
that masculine masculinity itself is
inherently toxic but rather that certain
traditionally masculine traits can
present or be depicted in a way that is
harmful destructive and feeds into
larger issues that as a culture we're
trying to work on things like jumping to
violence as the go-to solution for
problems lashing out at or rejecting
anything that appears to diminish one's
perceived manliness which is that the
root of a great deal of homophobia and
transphobia also there is sexually
driven possessiveness being protective
to the point of stifling the very people
that you are meant to be protecting ie
the dad with a shotgun and much much
more
the ultimate case in point example in
media may well be the villain of Mad Max
fury road
immortan joe joe himself and the culture
that he has built around him
is the very embodiment of toxic
masculinity he views his wives as his
personal property he has raised a
generation of young men to embrace a
self-destructive warrior culture where
they find glory in their own deaths even
though those deaths serve no one other
than Joe himself I mean why do you think
the vehicles all look like this
it's sacrificing practicality for
manliness oh and a quick side note yes
there is such a thing as toxic
femininity and it does show up in
entertainment just take a look at fatal
attraction or Mean Girls as prime
examples but the reason that doesn't get
talked about in the same way as toxic
masculinity is that traditionally
feminine traits cranked up until they
become flat-out harmful is virtually
always depicted as a bad thing in these
stories
whereas masculine traits taken to a
level of toxicity have oftentimes has
been depicted in a positive light for a
very long time
immortan joe may be the villain now but
if you ever go back to some of the early
days of say James Bond you will find
yourself watching a callous
self-destructive man drinking his way
through a life of empty sex and casual
murder and it's all shown to be awesome
until relatively recently this was
laudable behavior more often than not
that's why we talk about Matt toxic
masculinity in general which in turn is
why I feel it's important to highlight
the other side of that coin oh and just
in case anybody is wondering I do
actually like James Bond movies most of
them anyway it it's just an easy example
now to try and bring it back on track
many of the traits at the heart of toxic
masculinity protectiveness physical
strength defends through violence the
use of force in general self-sacrifice
etc these are not inherently bad things
they just get amped up to the point of
becoming toxic but all those sames
characteristics can be used and shown in
that highlights their positive
application and that is really what I
want to do in this video because you can
have a positive masculine character
without stripping away the traditional
masculine traits of strength protection
defense stoicism etc and I want to thank
my Twitter followers for reminding me of
some really stellar examples when I sort
of put the call-out on there sadly I'm
not gonna be using all of the
suggestions that people floated at me
many of them were more along the lines
of straight-up subversions of male
heroes because they actually lacked many
of the standard male heroic traits
examples of that would include Newt
Scamander and certain incarnations of
the doctor now these are great
characters and very valuable as we need
male heroes who display more than some
rigid list of manly traits but that
wasn't quite the angle I wanted to take
in this video so they're not gonna be
brought up again there were also some
amazing real-life examples offered up
but doing my due diligence on real-life
people is a bit more work than I feel
like I'm fit for so we're sticking with
fiction today also additionally and
finally if the actor or the writer
behind any of the examples I'm citing is
a problematic figure separate from the
character in question I'm not getting
bogged down in that
not today that's not to say that should
be ignored in the grand scheme of things
only that for this video I'm just
talking about the characters and leaving
as much baggage out of it as I can cool
cool so let's start big with the
Paragons of superheroes Superman and
Captain America now both these
characters have been around for a very
long time and have been reinterpreted
often enough that things have gone off
the rails for both of them at a few
points I'm not going to dwell on those
instances because that's not what we're
here to talk about I just want to
acknowledge that I am aware
that that's happened now both of these
men serve as the ultimate role models of
what heroes particularly masculine
heroes should be in their respective
universes they're the ultimate moral
authority to the point that usually the
best question anyone can ask themselves
is what would Captain America do what
would Superman do because both obviously
are strong and that may even be their
most problem that superpower is raw
strength but more importantly they serve
first and foremost as protectors it is
not a coincidence that caps weapon of
choice is a shield and that one of the
most iconic images of Superman is him
standing in the path of bullets they'll
apply force as needed but they do it in
service of protecting others that is
what they're here to do and violence is
not the only means of protection both
men are capable of great feats of
inspiration at their best they make the
people around them want to be better and
both are capable of great empathy
because there's more to protecting
people than just standing in the path of
physical danger and there may be nothing
better that exemplifies this then this
page which Mike Gillis of radio versus
the Martians podcast reminded me of
Wow I said I wouldn't deal with the
real-life figures I'm gonna bend that
slightly by talking about the film that
does depict real-life events but I can
sleep at night because I'm only talking
about the events people as the film
shows them and not delving into the
actual true reality at least that's what
I'm gonna tell myself Apollo 13 it
follows the 1970 space mission that went
wrong and the scramble of the astronauts
and the NASA team on the ground to get
the crew back to earth safely this was a
situation where panic on either and
either the people in space or the people
on the ground could have spelled doom
for the crew what's great about this is
it is a positive depiction of standing
strong moving forward and not getting
overly emotional about the situation and
it's about an entire team of men doing
it individually and collectively it's
not about one man who needed to get the
job done if any one of the men involved
had not stepped up the whole thing would
have failed it's both stoic strength and
team unity wrapped up in a terrific
package I'd heard similar praise about
the recent Ford V Ferrari but I haven't
seen that movie yet so I can't actually
delve into it too much now the TV show
Brooklyn nine-nine is actually a
cavalcade of positive masculinity
probably best embodied by sergeant Terry
Jeffords he is the ultimate papa bear
built like a piece of construction
equipment but never afraid to be soft
he's a loving father to his daughters
possesses immense strength but rarely
actually puts it to violent use and is
both an authority figure and a booster
for everybody else in the precinct in
the same show we have Captain Holt who
is masculine stoicism and emotional
suppression because remember boys don't
cry taken to an absolute extreme yet in
his own way he shows repeatedly too that
he cares deeply about the officers under
him and his mannerisms aren't an
affectation to hide his emotions that's
truly just how the man is and that's
okay even Jake the quintessential
manchild is
often an example of positive masculinity
normally this kind of character is
detrimental to a group dynamic
constantly undercutting Authority for no
reason other than for their own
amusement and jockeying for top dog
position
and frankly they tend to be big stupid
jerks who the audience is supposed to
love because of reasons and while Jake
has his moments of accidental problem
causing his playfulness is carefully
balanced to not interfere with this work
or get in the way of those around him
and when it does he owns up to that and
takes responsibility it's why his
relationship with Charles is so
important because that gives him an
outlet for his enthusiasm that could be
more of a problem if it was completely
unbridled he's a genuinely positive
example of the manchild he may have to
focus better at times but he doesn't
need to grow up in any big grand sense
because he's a good guy just the way he
is
Jake will actually work nicely as a
transition into masculine characters who
shed toxic elements over time Jake
didn't really need to do too much of
that since he doesn't exactly start off
awful just a little too self-absorbed
however there are some characters who
are clearly on the toxic end of things
who discard the worst of it over time
this can happen in movies where a
toxically masculine lead softens by the
end of the film the hard-drinking
emotionally stunted Eddie valiant from
Who Framed Roger Rabbit is a solid
example but the thing about movies like
that is it usually happens right at the
end and we don't get to see how this
Reformation actually plays out and
practice down the line so we often see
the points at which they become better
men but so rarely get to actually see
how life is actually better for them as
a result and that is why freaking love
Steve Harrington from stranger things I
won't lie Steve is the actual IMP
is for me to do this topic in the first
place so yeah I'm gonna give him a spot
of prominence season one steve is a
straight-up creep he's a violent bully
whose possessiveness of his girlfriend
is just ridiculous and honestly I was
kind of shocked he was allowed to live
through that first season but oh I'm so
glad he did because his journey from
high school top dog douchebag
to world's greatest babysitter to
amazing a lie is just the best thing
ever and a big part of what I love is
that it's not stripping him of the
traits that made him such a toll in
season one it's just redirecting them
Steve is a guy who's more than willing
to throw a punch and can be protective
to a degree that spills over into
possessiveness so season two hands of a
baseball bat gets him invested in
protecting Dustin same willingness to
use violence to protect what he cares
about redirected to positive use and
then there's the scene in season 3 where
his coworker Robin comes out to him as a
lesbian this scene is seriously one of
the best things I saw in 2019 there if
you haven't seen it they're both coming
down from a truth serum or more
accurately they are crashing there's a
clear chemistry between them and it's
obvious that Steve has himself a little
bit of a crush and then she tells him
that she's gay and it takes him a minute
but he pauses the wheels turned he
processes and then he shifts seamlessly
in torture into a traditional male buddy
good-natured teasing role he doesn't
freak out
he doesn't have to question himself or
his understanding of who Robin is he
just took in the new data pivoted
slightly and kept on moving season one
Steve could never have managed this but
season three Steve does it with ease and
that character journey is a thing of
magic to me now most of the examples
I've been giving so far have been from
relatively recent pieces of
entertainment but lest you think that
there was no positive masculinity before
the 22
please consider the specimen of Rocky
Balboa
what makes rocky special is not his
ability to dish out or inflict violence
I mean he can do that and the film makes
it clear that isn't why he's rude he's
worth rooting for and it isn't really
something he enjoys doing anyway the
reason Rocky is a hero is because of his
resilience not because of how much of a
beating he hands out but how much of one
he can take and keep standing on his
feet how many times he can get knocked
down and get back up and do it all over
again the six film and the franchise
actually had the character himself say
it best the world ain't all sunshine and
rainbows it's a very mean and nasty
place and I don't care how tough you are
it will beat you to your knees and keep
you there permanently if you let it you
me or nobody is gonna hit as hard as
life but it ain't about how hard you hit
it's about how hard you can get hit and
keep moving forward how much you can
take and keep moving forward that's how
weird it is done that's incredibly
masculine but it's not destructive the
way active violence is its admirable
because he won't let anything beat him
down not Apollo Creed not everyone
telling him he's too stupid to make
anything of himself not even life but
here's my favorite part about rocky
especially in that first film being
strong doesn't mean not feeling or not
showing emotions so much of media over
the years reinforced the real men don't
cry you have to put your feelings aside
get the job done and they just
reinforced that by example if not
explicit statement but what does rocky -
at the end of that first fight with
Apollo Creed he calls out for Adrian he
bellows out his need to connect with his
emotional core at this the highest
moment of his life so far and it's not
weakness
it is triumph and in a similar vein John
McClane specifically as depicted in the
first die hard movie now he's got some
traits that might lean towards the toxic
of things especially when we learn a
little bit more of the difficulties in
his marriage but what I want to
highlight is that McClain is not an
emotionless machine taking down the bad
guys he's scared he's hurt he needs
support he can't let the bad guys know
this for obvious reasons but the
audience gets to know we get to see this
badass who's been single-handedly taking
out well-armed well-trained group of
killers he leans on a practical stranger
for emotional support
he and out have connected as men in a
dire situation McLean's need for
emotional support is not shown as a flaw
and it makes him no less of a man and
I'll supporting him even opening up
about his own damage in order to do that
better and be a better support its a
complimentary display of strength
through vulnerability it takes a special
kind of bravery to admit that you need
help coping and to reach out for it and
it is wonderfully displayed here and we
can reach even further back than the 70s
or the 80s how about mr. Smith goes to
Washington where sheer pigheaded
stubborn rigidness is put to positive
use by having it supporting a strong
moral Center perhaps Henry Fonda as
juror number eight in the classic 12
Angry Men using every technique he can
muster from pleas for empathy to cold
hard logic to stand against wave after
wave of vengeful opposition or how about
the Defiant demand for equal respect
from the legendary Sidney Poitier in the
heat of the night and heaven forbid we
forget the amazing Atticus Finch in To
Kill a Mockingbird stoic style wore
protective crusading stands his ground
in the face of mounting odds a man to
admire for the ages
I could probably keep this going but I
want to hear from you folks about some
of your favorite examples of positive
masculinity because I guarantee there is
primal examples I have not touched on so
next time that you start to worry that
all men in entertainment are either
depicted as bad or have been retro
actively painted as such just remember
there are plenty of role models out
there past and present and to whatever
degree masculinity is part of your
identity I just hope you'll keep it
positive thanks for watching and I
encourage you to do the usual things
likes and subscribes and sharing of the
video it helps the channel grow and
keeps the algorithm from forgetting
about me if you want to lend a true
helping hand you'll find a link to my
patreon in the description it'd be
greatly appreciated but I will tell you
what to do because I'm not that
controlling and besides you're the
council I just run the meetings until
next time this council is a jerk
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]